I have not been working out regularly,
regularly for several years now.
Obviously I'm fat and lazy,
but I want to get after it.
So the question is,
should I go all in level nine,
destruction,
maximum madness or ease into it at level three.
Cruising.
Uh,
all right,
well this,
there's a couple of different approaches.
Now when I hear this,
first of all,
you don't want to get hurt,
right?
And you also don't want to make yourself try and do things that are so hard and
so painful that you can't do it repeatedly.
Yeah.
So if you just destroy yourself,
Matt,
what did he say?
If you destroy yourself,
level nine destruction,
maximum madness.
But then you can't work out for two more weeks.
Well guess what?
What'd you do in the mean?
No.
Let's say realistically you got Dom's comes.
Sure,
right?
Delayed onset muscle soreness.
Let's say you did so many burpees that your legs,
you couldn't sit down without your legs being in pain.
So you take,
so you take three days,
four days.
Have you ever had Dom's so bad that you took four days off?
No.
Okay.
Let's say you take three days off,
what did you do during those three days?
Did you hold the line?
Did you stay on the path or were you eating Cheetos on your colon?
That's what you are doing.
So if you destroy yourself to where you can't stay on the path,
that's not good.
You want to stay on the path.
I think doing something that you can handle or maybe something just beyond what
you can handle every single day is more important.
So going at a level,
not,
not cruising level,
not level three,
but let's,
let's find a solid level five where you can,
you're pushing yourself.
I write a thousand words a day when I'm writing and let you do the equivalent of
that.
Right?
The reason I read,
cause if I said,
okay,
I'll do it tonight.
I just say today I just have to write 5,000 words.
That's five hours.
We'll do I have five hours today.
No I don't.
Yeah,
I can squeeze out 52 minutes though and get a thousand words written that I can
do.
So that's,
that's what I think you needed to do.
You need to get consistent.
If you bite off more than you chew than you can chew your you,
you might very well choke on it.
So don't,
so don't do that to say,
so pick something realistic.
Do,
do people say that?
That must be a same time I heard it.
So if you bite off more than you can chew,
you might choke on it.
Did you make that up or you get that from somewhere?
I think I,
well I just,
I don't know.
I think I made it up,
but I'm sure someone like be like no,
this guy said it in 1978 yeah,
I heard it.
That's the beauty of it.
Good.
So pick something realistic like for something that you can handle and then get
after it.
Then the other thing here is he doesn't talk about his diet at all.
And that's clearly equally important and you have to change
your diet.
If you're gonna Change Your Life and you're going to change your health.
So stop eating sugar,
stop eating processed foods,
no more soda and juices and no more Gatorade
just to start with this or whatever it is.
Whenever it is that you're doing.
Uh,
whoever asked this question,
whatever,
you know what you're doing.
If you're eating donuts and don't,
don't eat donuts anymore,
stop.
Just stop eating those.
Yeah.
Get rid of that sugar,
sweetness craving thing.
Yeah.
And then just keep making your diet cleaner and cleaner as time goes by.
So
that's what I think.
Is there any time that it's good?
Because sometimes
I think it's good when people do go like,
alright man,
um,
Dolan.
Yeah.
Like I,
whatever happened,
they went up the staircase and they,
they,
they got all tired and they say,
you know what?
I'm done.
Yeah.
It starts tomorrow.
But I think in those cases,
most of the time,
who was it?
Who was it that we were talking to?
Talking to someone,
someone that they are,
I was talking to someone that their first thing they tried to do,
they couldn't do it all.
Like they tried to run three miles and they were like,
you know,
what?
Can't do it.
Can't run three miles.
Oh,
it might've been that guy.
There's a guy that's losing a bunch of weight on the interwebs.
Oh yeah.
That's what it is.
I think he's down in Texas.
Uh,
but he's trying to lose a lot of weight and you're first time he went to try to
go for run didn't happen.
That didn't happen.
So he had to just run less.
I had to just walk actually start slower.
So yeah,
you,
you start with what you can do,
but there is a little bit of,
there is,
I would try,
I would say this,
keep this one in the,
in the back of your mind,
there is the whole thing of like,
you know what?
I'm changing my life right now.
You'd go home,
you'd get the garbage can out,
you bring it into the kitchen,
you throw away the Twinkies,
you throw away the pop tarts,
you throw away the,
that you pour the,
the crappy soda down the drain and you get on the path and you just don't look
back.
Yeah.
That's a good thing to do too.
But again,
if that person's 300 pounds,
they're not going to be able to do.
I mean,
they're going to push themselves.
Yeah.
They could push themselves too hard,
I guess so you just gotta be careful.
Yeah.
See,
it's funny when I'm,
when I'm kind of looking at the question,
I'm like,
well,
obviously you want to start slow,
right?
Obviously,
but then I don't feel like you hear about these guys.
Just like how you said they just,
they throw everything away.
They were like,
I'm a new different person right now.
I think we're,
we're,
we're crossing streams here or I am,
there's diet and then there's like a workout.
Yeah.
Because Diet,
you can pretty much go cold Turkey today.
Yeah.
It limits,
and you may or may not be able to relate to this,
but if you cook strait extreme on your day,
like all of a sudden you're hit with these,
the byproducts of changing your diet,
especially if you'd like,
like mountain dew every single day.
Right.
And you just,
all of a sudden,
boom,
stopped doing a month.
You'll go through stuff that you might not expect,
like the craving will hit you so hard.
I on friggin minimal doses of mountains.
Yeah.
Basically.
Basically I'm going to say no,
just stop drinking mountain there.
You don't need it.
I,
yeah.
And I dig it.
And you're going to go through withdrawals,
right?
Yeah.
Through caffeine withdrawals and sugar withdrawals.
You're going to get the,
the,
the Keto flu and all those things are gonna happen and it's going to be rough.
But yeah,
but they'll just say it like that is going to be real fucked.
That talk.
Hey Bro.
Seriously,
if you go into that and you experience these types of things and it's gonna
apply to everything,
by the way,
any big changes that you make where you,
you have to deprive yourself of these bad things that you've become kind of
addicted to or whatever,
you're going to go through all kinds of changes.
And that goes for workout too,
by the way.
Cause like just the soreness alone.
Oh Dang.
I wasn't expecting the soreness.
Oh,
I'm like tired now because the workout like was kind of hard.
It's like,
Oh shit.
I wasn't expecting that.
I was extracting the field right after my workout.
Hell,
everyone says or whatever.
So you're gonna run into all these little things that no one tells you about.
And then it's like,
well,
I didn't sign up for that little part of it.
And then what about that little part?
And then you're going to impact the Diet thing.
I think you're wrong.
I think the Diet thing,
I think if you're good,
I think it's very,
I think it's easier,
in fact to just be like,
I'm done.
It's not like,
okay,
you know what?
I'm only going to eat a quarter bag of Cheetos a day from now on.
I don't think that works.
I think you've gotta be like,
no,
no.
She does not know Cheetos in my house.
But I do think that you could work out so hard that you're so sore that you,
that you say,
Oh man,
I'm just to like kind of like the Jujitsu question earlier on.
Like you could be,
what if someone's so sore that they can't do their job right and they're just
sore all day at work?
Well that's not cool.
So I think for Diet you can,
you can go cold Turkey or actually called steak or hot steak.
And then I think for working out is the one you,
you,
you figure out what you can do and you push it a little bit harder,
but you don't go level nine,
maximum destruction madness.
I think you're wrong respectfully.
And which part do you think I'm wrong on that?
I think if you go extreme with your diet,
I think that it'll work for some people for sure.
Uh,
but depending on who you are,
but I think you're more,
if you go extreme with the Diet you don't like slowly phase out or what's the
notes you're thing,
you know what's interesting?
I don't know if you remember,
I read a letter a while back on the podcast about a guy that had red way,
the warrior kid and he like fixed his life and man,
that guy did what you're saying.
He just made little changes.
He made little changes along the way.
So maybe it's personal,
it's probably personality.
In fact,
let's just go ahead and say it's personality.
Some people are gonna just have to get the damn Cheetos out of their house.
All of them.
Yeah.
And some people say,
you know what,
I'm only going to have this one cup full of Cheetos every day.
Yeah.
And even that's okay,
but,
but here's where you gotta be careful.
You may lie to yourself
and you can lie to yourself.
Hey,
you can lie to yourself on the,
Ah,
you know,
I don't really that,
that not that big of a deal today.
If I just have two cups of Cheetos and say,
yeah,
nine cubs the Cheetos later,
but you still bothered him.
Cheeto dust and respectfully,
I don't like your Cheetos example.
Why?
Because you're like,
I'm going to allow myself to eat.
Okay.
Don't allow yourself Cheetos.
That's not how small of a change you're going to make you.
If you're not gonna eat Cheetos anymore,
you're not going to eat Cheetos anymore.
I'm saying like if you go extreme on your diet,
let's say you eat would,
wouldn't you say what you're saying is,
hey,
I'm going to change my diet.
Okay,
sir.
I used to eat every day.
I'd eat a whole bag of Cheetos and now I'm only gonna eat one cup of Cheetos
from the bag of day.
That's improvement.
It is improvement.
It's small improvement.
And if I could do that,
then why?
Why is that not okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
If you choose to do that,
but okay,
now we're going into the specifics of a certain person's thing.
I would say this,
this is more along the lines of what I'm thinking as far as specific examples.
If you're going to go,
if I'm going to eat one bag of Cheetos,
obviously that's not all I'm eating.
I'm eating other stuff.
I'm the small change is I'm not gonna eat Cheetos anymore.
I'm going to cut out Cheetos.
That's it.
I'm still not eating that good.
You know,
I'm cut up Cheetos or let's say a,
I get um,
you know,
drive through every day,
three times a day.
Okay.
I won't get dragged through anymore or all.
That's a big change.
Not necessarily,
depending on what you get going from three drive throughs a day,
two to zero.
The how's that?
Not a big,
that's a big challenge is going from like,
and there are certain people,
actually I was talking to someone the other day that had lost 150 pounds a
female.
And it was interesting,
her nutritionist,
she hired a nutritionist and the nutritionist said,
okay,
what are the foods you can't live without?
Yeah.
And we'll work around those.
That's a pretty cool thing.
And what she said was,
I need cheeseburgers and fries.
So then what she got told was something along the lines of,
okay,
you can have cheese burger and fries on Friday.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
So it was the same.
So they can,
instead of,
you know,
this,
this whole thing of I can never read it.
Now what I'm saying is there are people,
and I think I'm one of these people where it's like,
Oh,
if I have cheeseburgers and fries today,
well then I might as well just get a mint chocolate chip milkshake with it.
And if I did that tonight,
then you know what,
tomorrow morning,
Hey,
after you get done training,
maybe if you know that she's Burger's good yesterday,
I'll climb.
So maybe it's my own personal weakness,
but for me,
I,
I'd prefer to be just like on the path.
Yeah.
That's why the 80 20 rule,
and I talked about this in the field manual,
the 80 20 rule,
maybe it works for some people and I guess it does work for me,
but I'd rather just be straight on the program,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
And,
and then,
and you know what,
you know Tim Ferriss has that thing where,
where he's talked about the thing where he goes six days hardcore strict and
then the seventh day you literally eat whatever you want as much as you can.
And I tried that.
I have,
and it's really,
really good because you feel really,
really good.
Not only physically but just about the whole d I'm on the program and you kind
of know.
And on that,
on that cheat day you do,
they call it the Cheetah,
you eat whatever you want and you don't feel any guilt at all.
Even when you're on the 80 20 it's like you have to be coming off a real strong
weak to like be to feel good appeal.
Cheeseburgery like cheeseburgers are good too.
Yeah.
And that's really that bad of a cheat day or a cheeseburger.
Fries,
fries.
Then you're starting to go into it for sure.
But
like,
you know,
a cheat day,
cheat day,
like as Tim Hill,
it'll be like for real,
like a whole thing of donuts.
Box a cookie.
Yeah.
Whatever you want.
Straight up whatever you want us to discuss.
Here's the thing though,
with when you,
when you start to eat healthy and then you try to eat a whole box of donuts,
you after like one,
two,
three,
maybe six,
eight donuts,
you going to be like in six donuts.
Easy.
Six donuts in one setting.
Gosh,
you know those,
I think they're called intimates old fashioned there.
The little chocolate donuts.
No.
You know what?
A full size donut.
Straight up.
They're kind of little bit bigger too,
you know?
Okay.
You know,
uh Oh man.
I can't even fathom eating six donuts.
Ever since I started talking so much smack about donuts.
I can't literally,
can never have one again in my life.
Yeah,
no,
you're not allowed for sure.
A hundred percent a hundred percent not even even have a bite.
Even if you are,
like,
if someone was like,
Hey,
just out when I was a little kid,
my parents would buy the chocolate dawn.
That's the hostess chocolate covered in chocolate.
And those things are good.
Yeah.
You can't even have one of those again.
Nope.
I did the six day cheap program.
Nobody,
even then you can't,
I can't do it.
You know,
you know the old fashioned donut is right.
It's like a doughnut with a hole in it right now.
It's called old fashion donuts.
They're like,
um,
it's,
they're kind of glazed in,
almost like a,
not,
they're not crispy,
but they're kind of hardy are hard and on the outside and then their regular
soft on the inside and they have this glaze over them.
Okay.
So I think it's,
I forget the name.
I think it might be intimate,
but they have old fashioned donuts where they're not as hard,
but they're kind of hard and they're just bigger.
Anyway.
Those are my favorite ones.
And I used to get chocolate milk and heat up the chocolate milk.
Looks like hot chocolate and donuts and all.
Yeah,
easy money.
Like I'll eat two boxes of those for sure.
Oh,
I used to anymore.
Oh yeah.
So nine point there is on a cheat day you just go like,
no shame.
But after,
the thing is you can't just eat doughnuts four times a day or three times.
You don't feel good.
Like your stomach gets all upset in.
The more healthy you eat,
the more it's going to be like that.
So the longer you're on the path,
you start like if you ate some donuts,
like the other day we went to the Belmont Park and I ate some ice cream,
some mint chocolate chip ice cream.
Was it good?
Fine.
It was good.
But you know the kids are doing whatever's tracks through the night.
Yeah.
You eat a big,
large double.
You know what?
After.
After that you're like,
Bro,
I don't feel right.
You know,
so unless you're just committed to eat it,
cause I don't know,
you don't want to waste it or something like that,
you're going to be like,
aw my cheat.
Your cheat day is not going to be that bad.
This is what I'm saying.
Oh okay.
But I'm still do have that fight.
I'll make it happen.
It depends on what it is.
Yeah.
You can pump some Chili fries or something.
I don't like Chili fries.
All right.
So yeah,
maybe what's the verdict then?
I think just in the middle of the road.
Nut.
The whole study life balance.
Yeah.
So you're saying balance as well.
I'll tell you though,
man,
if that balance doesn't work for you,
you're going to have to step it up.
You're gonna have to go hardcore.
I'd give yourself two weeks,
two weeks for a balanced approach on the diet side.
If you can't get your shit under control and two weeks you got to go hardcore,
you've got to get in there with garbage clinic can throw away the Twinkies,
throw away everything else.
That's crap.
And your fridge and go hardcore that go and start with a fast too right now.
Hey,
a fast as awesome a faster way.
I don't even know that there's that much to expect.
The only for a day,
if you never done it before,
it's not that big of a deal.
There's no little stuff.
Don't eat your day.
There's little,
there's not take you from a normal human being.
Just little stuff that you,
if you're not,
if you go in and not prepared for it,
then you're like,
oh,
I actually think the more you think about and prepare for it,
the more psychologically ordered it is just to be like,
oh yeah,
you know what?
I woke up this morning.
I haven't eaten last night call.
I'm not going to eat until tonight.
Every time.
That's a fast,
yeah,
so I end it like that when I'm like,
I'm not going to until this.
Then I go through little stuff,
but if I just happy,
if I'm too into work,
I only drink coffee and I forget and I'm like,
Dang,
if if I eat and I haven't ate for like 12 hours or 16 and I'll be like,
oh,
I'll just go another three.
That's my 15 cause it's like 15 right.
15 hours is when your body starts to kind of shift to like I think 15 whatever
it is called.
So I'll just wait that shower.
It's like cool.
Done.
But if it planet,
that's when,
yeah,
I dunno.
Let it depends on who you are,
man.
I agree with the fans off.
Yeah.
That's a great way to kick things off and get like jump onto the path.
This junk bond with a fast.
Yep.
Hey,
go see your doctor or whatever.
Do you have to go see a doctor to fast 24 hours if you've been probably,
yeah,
close.
Uh,
uh,
fat,
Lazy,
you know,
especially if you're older or something like that.
I think seeing it talks about how to get a personal trainer.
Depends on what you mean by Helmut Young Woman.
I just talked to,
she's like personal trainer and nutritionist hired in both lost a hundred and
whatever pounds.
So yeah,
I think she was an excess of 300 pounds.
Yeah.
And when I met her she's completely normal.
Right.
Like you know completely like you wouldn't even suspect that she had any weight
trouble in her life.
Yeah.
That's pretty amazing.
So hire the trainer,
hire the,
the the nutritionist.
Yeah,
I think so.
I think that helps.
I always looked at it like why would I hire like a trainer or something like
that when I can kind of look up that stuff.
But here's the thing,
I went in with this bias like,
cause I kind of had a background in it so I'm like why would I can just go look
and,
but I'm looking it up but I have all this other knowledge.
The same rule.
You try it for two weeks,
see if you can keep yourself on the path and if you can't got to bring someone
in.
Right.
Here's what I like.
Hire a trainer but not like an everyday.
It's like a once a week trainer who can get you on a little program.
Yeah,
that's you know it's going to depend on who you are straight up.
You know who can keep you on.
Yeah.
That's the biggest part of all this and I've said this a billion times like you
know what you need to do.
Yeah.
You know what you need to do.
You know?
If you can't get yourself to do it,
maybe you need to get someone to help you do it.
Yeah.
The weird thing is like nutritionists and stuff,
you can get nutritionist that could come to you and be like,
okay,
we're going to go put you on a low fat diet.
You know what?
You'd be really not good senior in the wrong direction.
I don't know how many.
Do you think there's still nutritionists that are doing that right now?
There are.
I know there are actually there are out there,
so you've got gotta be careful that
check
next west.
Last thing that,
I'm not going to draw it out.
But you said you know what you need to do in one time.
You said imagine what your day would look like.
Like if you,
like everything you did
was you did the things that you knew you're supposed to do kind of thing.
Well,
the full,
the full statement is if you wrote down tonight what you were supposed to do
tomorrow and then you did the things that you were supposed to do,
imagined how that day would feel and imagine what you get done in that day.
Yeah.
And then imagine if you did that everyday for a week.
And imagine if you did that everyday for a month and he did it for a year and
imagine where your life would be.
Your life would be in a completely different trajectory.
Completely.
Completely different.
Yeah.
And that's true with working out.
That's true with nutrition.
That's true with business.
That's true in education,
that truth,
knowledge,
truth,
everything,
everything.
Yeah.
Kind of know what we're supposed to do.
Oh,
I thought you were going to say some people don't know what to do.
And that could be the case.
Some people they've never worked out before,
and if you're a person that's never worked out before,
you probably need to bring someone into the game that's going to help show you
how to work out.
If never done any reading about eating and you have no idea what's going to be
good for you,
you're probably a person that might need to bring someone into the game to help
you get over that.
Yeah,
and it's still completely goes with exactly what he said.
It's like you know what to do and even to help that you know what not to do.
Like when you're about to make decisions,
I'm gonna do this or not do this.
Like you know which one is you should or shouldn't do.
So let's say I don't know anything about working out,
but I know I have to get in shape.
We all know and you know,
we all know when we got to get in shape.
So then you know you're going to hire somebody.
You know you've got to do something.
You know that you shouldn't just be like,
oh,
well I'm not going to do it.
I don't know.
I'm not going to do it.
Things to do tomorrow and a trainer.
Yeah,
join a gym.
Get a trainer.
Yeah.
I don't know what to do.
Okay.
This is what you can do.
Find out what to do.
There you go.
Then in that case,
so you,
it makes sense.
Sometimes when you put things in,
just say stuff,
just put it on the table.
Just starts to make sense.